- [Voiceover] So you've moved to a city
and bought a car.
Now it's time to learn to drive
like an (bleep) hole.
("Jolly Shoppers")
Last time on driving like an (bleep) hole
we covered texting at red lights,
tailgating, and driving 50 miles an hour
in the left lane.
This time, parking.
You're in a city so it's very important
to learn how to park like an (bleep) hole.
When looking for a spot,
drive as slow as you want
no matter how congested
the area is. (cars honking)
Oh look, an empty spot.
Yes!
There might be room for two cars here,
but not the way you drive.
Make sure you leave
plenty of room in between
you and the next bumper.
Not enough room for a car, (buzzer sounds)
just enough room for let's say a golf cart
or a dolphin.
Perfect.
That'll make someone mad later.
If you have a smaller car,
parking garages are
just the place for you.
When in a crowded parking garage,
make sure you go right
to the front of the spot.
There it is.
Make sure it's enough for someone
to think they've finally
found an open one,
only to crush their dreams.
Don't worry about validating your ticket.
You can probably just use
a credit card at the exit.
(horns honking irritably)
Next time we'll cover
never using your blinker,
putting your entire
family's lives at risk,
and making sure you get the most
out of your insurance premium.
(upbeat hip-hop music)